it's day 2 d 3 i'm down here at nintendo
with ali to check out tri Force heroes
the new zelda game for 3ds i didn't I
don't think anyone saw this coming this
is a brand new announcement yeah I'm
super excited I also was like super
psyched because I really didn't get a
chance to play a ton of Four Swords
Adventures or four stores and so I'm
like oh lolli player Zelda this is what
I've been waiting for forever and you
like you get to like dress up and stuff
so but we'll talk about that later yeah
and it's interesting too because now
there's online multiplayer you know the
four swords games were local only but
this is great because now people can
actually play these games together no
matter where they are yeah yeah and so
we've got online we've got local of
course and we've also got download play
and what's really cool is we might get
to see it later what you can do is like
to see little emoticons on the bottom
screen and you can press them and it's
like link will do like a pompom cheer if
something goes right or you can be like
no or pick me up or whatever so it's
just a really good way to communicate
with people whether you're playing
locally or online cuz I guess there
isn't voice chat at this point right
okay well so let's take a look at what
they're doing back here can you explain
the the structure of the game I mean is
this a big grand adventure or are we
looking at you know bite-sized levels
sort of from the Four Swords Adventures
you know style right right so we've got
a town and this town is part of this
kingdom that's all about fashion right
like everybody loves fashion everybody's
a fashionista and that's where you go to
like it you close the costumes that you
wear in the dungeon but the way that
it's structured is there's just a whole
bunch of dungeons you can pick from and
so you start off in the town and then
you go when you're going to play single
player and multiplayer so three players
you go into this you know area where you
select that and then you select the
dungeon that you want to do and then you
go out on your adventure with your
buddies and so junctions are structured
with like I think it's like three
sections for done too and there's a boss
at the end and so you have to work
together to defeat the to get through
the dungeon your share hearts you need
to use this new totem mechanic which is
like sacking the links up to solve
puzzles you needed to be enemies
together so the bosses together and then
at the end of the boss you need to get
your own
chest which contains an item that you
can then use to help make the costume
some like that so how do the costumes
work exactly do you collect these by you
know spending rupees that you find her
in the you know during the game and what
sort of abilities will people expect to
be able to play around with right right
so there's a there's a town and where
you're kind of costume shop is located
and we are going to into too many
details about like how you crap them
stuff like that you will need rupees um
but some of the costumes that we're
showing up now let's see let's see looks
like there's two people wearing the
Zelda dress and one person wearing the
Kokiri outfit so the Kokiri outfit and
gives you more arrows to shoot so if
you're going into a dungeon that uses
the bow that's a really good one to pick
there's the bomb outfit which gives you
a bigger palm there's the Zelda dress
and the Zelda dress is one of my
personal faves because what happens is
you put it on and if you defeat an enemy
or you like breakage are you're more
likely to get a heart then another
person who's wearing a different costume
there's also the lucky lounge where we
just basically like silly jammies and
that makes it so you're more likely to
basically dodge a hit so you might get
hit but you won't take damage so and
there's going to be more costumes as
well that we're not going to know
details about but there's going to be
lots of good stuff for people to try out
maybe a chance of amiibo support with
other series introducing costumes knows
right imagination go away with that so
one thing I think a lot of people are
wondering about because this is a
multiplayer game how does it play when
you're by yourself I saw something
during the presentation regarding the
use of dolls how do those work they
completely AI driven do you control them
what's the situation there yep so the
way that single player works is you
basically in control of three different
links and you have to switch between
them so whereas multiplayer is each link
is going on at you know the exact same
time they're all moving in different
directions in single-player it's more
methodical so multiplayer you've got
like this hectic like okay everybody got
to work together let's do this super
quick where a single players like okay I
have to think about and you know I need
to put this link here so I can get that
link over on that button and then
link to push that blog so it's a little
bit more methodical a little bit more
kind of thought out as you're going
since it is that single player you know
you're controlling all three links kind
of at the same time but in turn if that
makes sense okay well so tri Force
heroes is coming out this fall correct
okay and new 30s only or every 30 s
orcas come it is compatible with the 3ds
family awesome Thank You Ali thanks for
watching us at gamespot stay tuned for
more news about intended when the rest
of the great games at the show